très élégant quoique racée avec une vi
nations
bien sûr il était une fois l'amérique
once upon a time in america mais si vous
préférez le poignant tous les goûts ce
soir à terre
ne rit pas de toute manière ces deux
hommes deux femmes car ils sont de la
même trempe de la même veine j'ai
l'impression d'achat ne pouvait pas la
première rencontre puisque c'est comme
ça je m'en vais et joely cantine ainsi
venus d'argentine et rtr votre invité à
partager
il ya quelque chose d un look et
internationale
moi je prends le risque quoi condition
que toi tu sois là et que tu gères plus
de sujets en tout cas du genre de
moments de ne pas qui que tu sois le
président de tout ça parce que j'ai au
fond va se fait pour toi une profonde
confiance à fond de confiance en toi
qu'elle avait lâché l'international où
elle se lamentait-elle pour joue
seulement pour l'interview massivement
water polo et le sucre
une mission même si ça semble être des
banalités
il est important de le dire il est
important de se battre pour que le
football revient au footballeur et pour
que le business ne bouffe pas ce qui a
été notre rêve
pourtant passé
ah mais merlus à moudre moi c'est ça
fait beaucoup demain la finale de voir
une épreuve jouée par ordinateur chose
que je n'arrive pas à comprendre mais
peuvent jouer mon ordinateur est allé
chercher le début de la partie
dc
il a fait ce qu'il fallait sur un
terrain et je suis c'est un moment que
je que je respecte comminges et comme je
respecte mon père du frère ma main des
hommes qui malgré tous les moments
exceptionnels de leur existence mais
également tous les coups bas dont ils
ont été les victimes n'ont pas fermé
leur que oui
décidément tant qu'il y aura